[Music]
meantime the palms casino officially
closed at the beginning of the pandemic
but after almost two years it's going to
reopen this spring it's got brand new
owners now there's still no word on an
exact date but sally jeremiah showing us
the opportunities ahead for our
community and for the property who
hasn't been to the palms yet it's fun
get ready las vegas the palms is back
palms is a magical place there's a sense
of community here that really you just
don't find anywhere else mike wassinger
is the director of human resources as
they get ready to open the doors again
to new and former team members we're
actively recruiting and hiring for a
variety of positions from food and
beverage to the casino housekeeping evs
hotel operations
security really all the
all the areas that we have and here at
palms they're looking to provide the
community with 1200 new job
opportunities i've been looking for new
careers daniel curiel has lived in las
vegas for 22 years and has been a union
carpenter for nine he's been out of work
for five months and eager for new
opportunities i've been looking i've
been applying everywhere and it's been
hard i actually applied to them so
it's hopefully it goes good and daniel
isn't alone as robert gaul from delaware
ohio says he is looking to relocate to
las vegas he wants a job in technology i
would love to get on the gaming floor
somewhere or behind the scenes any
opportunities where jobs are created and
added to the
is
you know perfect for me we're excited to
bring back a lot of places that guests
and team members love like scotch 80
prime
ghost bar will make its iconic return
back to palms and the iconic and famous
shark centerpiece is ready to greet
guests salihanamiyo live local now now
hiring events will officially begin
tomorrow morning they will run all the
way through the 10th of march again
leaders are looking to fill housekeeping
dealer and security positions you can
find a full detailed list of the events
visit our website 8newsnow.com
[Music]